So, the last type of partners are actually key suppliers. There are two types of key suppliers.
One which you actually outsource part of your company to a third party.
It might be your accounting functions. It might be some of your sales.
It might be something as simple as doctors looking at x-rays
are now done by trained technicians in India.
It might be part of your supply chain for sub-assemblies or you might outsource
your entire manufacturing line, which we used to have here in the United States
to a third-party company much like Apple does with Foxconn
or your key suppliers might be traditional direct suppliers.
They simply ship your components, raw materials, iron, and ore for you to make steel, etc.
In the old days, we used to think of suppliers as not a partnership but just simply a cost to goods.
Nowadays, we understand to get the most efficient use out of our resources,
we really need a relationship that treats them like partners.
We both need to be in this to win.
We both need to understand that this is more than just a financial transaction.
So, as your startup grows, start looking for partners where you are more than just a checklist
and they're just more of a source of material and try to establish long and lasting relationships.